well new legislation would make
year-round daylight savings time
permanent and you know what that means
that would mean that many of us would be
going to work or maybe going to school
in the dark sleep experts say the change
could be bad for our overall health and
safety john langler explains what some
doctors think is a better option
spring forward fall back save time lose
time which one should the u.s stick with
if it sticks with one at all you
probably have a strong opinion on making
the adjustment when the clocks have to
change people
just
don't want uh darkness when they go to
come back from work it doesn't it just
doesn't make sense i like that it's not
going to be dark anymore because i can
go out i feel like i won't be as tired
losing an hour an hour and a half in
some parts of the country because of
daylight a bill making daylight saving
time permanent is gaining steam with
lawmakers the american academy of sleep
medicine agrees with eliminating
seasonal time changes but instead
recommends year-round permanent standard
time which gives us more light in the
morning and less at night it aligns more
with our body's internal clock if we go
into permanent daylight saving time then
in the winter months the sun will not be
rising until well later than it
currently is so in some places well
after 8 a.m that's going to make it very
difficult for people to wake up and to
function data shows there are more
significant health and safety risks when
we spring forward an hour in march that
includes more car crashes mood disorders
and increased risk of heart attacks and
strokes dr lisa meltzer is with national
jewish health with our cardiac rhythms
and our health
those are certainly impacted when our
rhythms get off and when we're not
getting enough sleep dr meltzer warns
that longer days and lighter afternoons
might be enticing but must be weighed
against the negative impacts of getting
up in the dark
if the house passes the sunshine
protection act bill and president biden
signs it it would take effect in 2023